fondée au 12e siècle le prieuré d'orsan
de l'ordre de fontevraud accueil
religieux et religieuses
durant cinq siècles or sans connaît la
paix la prospérité
à la révolution le prieuré est vendu
comme exploitation à des causes jusque
dans les années 50
en 1990 le lieu est en ruine un
architecte patrice taravella achète le
prieuré et engage rénovation et re
création des jardins d'inspiration
médiévale
cj guillaume être jardinier qui recrée
ces jardins où se mêlent intimement le
profane et le sacré les jardins sont on
sort seulement un but donc que je
utilitaire est symbolique et de surcroît
tout est axé sur un jardin premier
central qui est le jardin du cloître ou
de méditation c'est un jardin d'esprit
ans alors ils utilitaires également dans
le sens où pour passer du nord au sud de
l'est à l'ouest
les religieux les religieuses passe
parce qu atre et puis surtout la grosse
symbolique c'est qu'il représente le
premier des jardins l'éden ou adam et
eve apparaissent à l'époque totalement
clos le cloître est un lieu de prière et
de méditation solitaire qui représente
le paradis l'éden nourri par quatre
fleuves symbolisée ici par une fontaine
à 4 g/j vous imaginez suivant la règle
en entrant dans le cloître un ordre de
marche c'est à dire on rentre on tourne
toujours à gauche
eh bien vous ne pouvez jamais rencontré
quelqu'un face à vous ce qui fait vous
n'êtes pas tenté de discuter et de
parler puisque les religieux était
astreint au silence comment laisser en
suivant la le plan de victor
les jardins religieux médiévaux sont
conçus pour être vus du ciel
la vision de dieu il faudra la
renaissance pour que le jardin soit fait
pour être vu par l'homme un jardin plus
esthétique que symbolique
le jardin monastère est par excellence
le jardin nourricier
donc c'est la nourriture du corps et de
l'esprit
ici nous sommes dans le potager donc
c'est la nourriture pour le corps ou
sont présentés ce qu'on appelle les
plantes aromatiques les condiments et
puis les légumes racines les légumes
fruits toutes ces choses là qui pou qui
peuvent être consommés donc pour nourrir
le corps et l'aider à se développer
c'est également l'endroit où le public
peut voir une caractéristique du des
jardins médiévaux
ce sont ces éléments très c'est avec des
gaules est de châtaignier sur des pieux
fixé seulement dans le sol qui nous
permettent de faire des petits clos des
séparations partout dans les jambes pour
recréer ces jardins gill s'est appuyé
sur les manuscrits d'époque et leur
enluminures comme lady de charlemagne
qui recommandait la culture de certains
végétaux comestibles ou médicinaux ainsi
chaque monastère cultivait potager et
erbil arius alors pourquoi nous avons
des jardins de plantes médicinales dans
les monastères
il ya plusieurs raisons éventuellement
c'est tout d'abord dans la règle de
saint benoît
les religieux doivent cultiver les
plantes médicinales connaître leurs
propriétés et dispenser les bons soins
aux gens qui sont malades qui en ont
besoin
le prieuré d'orsan révèle douze jardins
mais nous nous en tenons aux quatre
principaux quatre jardins qui boucle le
cycle de la vie le cloître symbole de la
naissance de l'humanité
le potager le jardin des simples qui
offrent croissance et santé enfin le
verger là où les religieux était enterré
sous une herbe verte symbole de
féliciter en aparté gilles nous confie
qu'il s'est construit ici à travailler
et à faire visiter ses paysages de
savoir on est hors du temps ici on
conjugue la vie aux médiévales donc il
ya vraiment d'autres dimensions
on apprend à regarder le jardin
autrement qu'avec les yeux ce qu'il faut
y mettre du coeur il faut y mettre de
l'intelligence est allé chercher l'idée
qu'il ya derrière les symboles que l'on
raconte un petit peu partout donc c'est
vraiment un lieu d'instruction c'est
pour ça que je me plais à dire que les
jardins nous recensons des jardins
cultivés dans tous les sens du terme
propre site